on retrouve tout de suite en tout cas
notre invité noan à noir noir noir merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes délégué
syndical de vigie police
on en parlait à l'instant avec alexis
poulain les deux suspects ont bien été
arrêtés et sont actuellement en garde à
vue c'est une nouvelle rassurante
non moi je ne me rassure pas de si peu
parce que si on réfléchit à la période
qu'on a traversé il ya quelques années
de la période à deux menaces terroristes
intense notamment les attentats du 13
novembre ou même ceux de charlie hebdo
d'ailleurs on peut comprendre qu'on
n'est jamais à l'abri d'un sur attentats
ou des attaques coordonnées c'est à dire
que le 13 novembre on a eu un commando
qui a lancé une première offensive au
stade de france et un commando qui
recchi qui a suivi sur les terrasses et
sur le bataclan au moment de charlie
hebdo on a eu une première attaque dames
et 10 coulibaly de dos que dans un stade
on a ensuite eu la taxe charlie hebdo
ensuite on a eu la la policière de
montrouge puis l'hyper cacher donc vous
voyez moi je crie pas victoire trop vite
d'autant que je martèle depuis des
années qu dehors de tout contexte le
vendredi est une journée à risque c'est
à dire que c'est une journée propice à
l'attentât suicide
donc nous sommes aujourd'hui comme par
hasard pour la dixième et la quinzième
fois consécutive un jour d'attentats
commis un vendredi donc il n'ya pas de
hasard c'est purement relatif j'irai à
la quand on dira à l'islamisme c'est à
dire pour qui connaît la religion
musulmane on sait que le vendredi est le
jour saint de l'islam jours durant
lequel il est recommandé de mourir en
martyr pour les extrémistes en tout cas
de noah manoir j'ai toujours pas
confirmé un c c'est vous qui dites mais
l'attentât islamique l'attaquent
islamique n'est toujours pas confirmée
par là par la préfecture de police de
paris
ah oui moi je viens d'entendre un
magistrat antiterroriste compagnie du
premier ministre qui nous disent l
inverse puisqu'il sait le
le parquet national anti terroriste
s'est saisi de la sphère donc cliqué on
n'a pas dû avoir les mêmes informations
moi je crois avoir une confirmation il
ya moins de cinq minutes que qu'il
s'agissait bel et bien d'un attentat à
prêt à écouter je fectivement je laisse
le bénéfice du doute
c'est pas dans l'attentât où on est
d'accord mais pas d'une attaque
terroriste islamique
ah oui effectivement il s'agissait
peut-être d'un extrémiste je me retourne
pardonnez moi
nous passons en tout cas moi pour eux
j'ai pardon j'ai comment dire une
connaissance de certains éléments
puisque je suis en contact avec un
certain nombre de vos confrères de la
presse que j'ai appelé quelques contacts
sur l' agence première ligne donc il
faut savoir que dans les faits qui ont
été rapportés donc là l'une des victimes
grièvement blessées avait été frappé à
la tête avec une feuille de boucher
c'est à dire que l'individu s'est
approché des locaux et à porter un coup
d'une puissance extrême sur la tête de
la première victime
donc qui semble dont le pronostic vital
ne serait pas engagé mais à qui on va
souhaiter un très bon rétablissement
nous écouter l'assaillant serait âgé de
18 ans totalement inconnu des services
de police avec un profil résident donc
cesser ce n'était pas a priori quelqu'un
qui aurait grandi en france ou que ça
symbolise une fois de plus
malheureusement il faut toujours le
répéter mais croyez-moi ça avec beaucoup
d'amertume l'échec des services de
renseignement puisque quand on cosaisi
la dg d'interrompre un homme noir
puisque comme vous vous avez vous avez
suivi un tout à l'heure à l'intervention
de jean castex la la santé
il ya des victimes ne serait en tout cas
selon le premier ministre pas en danger
oui tout à fait c'est ce que j'ai à vous
dire le pronostic vital n'est pas engagé
la personne a été frappé avec une
violence inouïe à la tête avec une
feuille de boucher effectivement et dieu
merci cette personne va s'en sortir mais
ça n'enlève rien à la cruauté à la
barbarie de l'acte donc écoutez moi je
mets sans relation avec l'âge de
l'assaillant c'est-à-dire de l'auteur
présumé qui est âgé de 18 ans donc ça 18
ans tout comme l'était ga l'auteur de
l'attentât de saint-etienne du rouvray
comment est-ce qu'à 18 ans est ce qu'on
peut se radicaliser au point de
commettre des atrocités pareil au coeur
de paris donc ça pose question il va
falloir effectivement peut être
réfléchir à des questions de fond sur la
sécurité et le renseignement
l'anti terrorisme en général mais qui va
falloir je m'appelle je me permets de
vous interrompre encore une fois le
profil à vous parliez à l'instant du
profil des suspects à ces profils ont
vite fuité sur sur les réseaux sociaux
est ce que ça peut être un problème pour
pour l' enquête de la police
non je ne pense pas parce que vous savez
en fin de compte l' enquête de la police
va définir a posteriori la façon de saut
ce dont ont eu lieu les événements mais
de toute façon comme je vous le disais
moi en tant que policier j'ai un
sentiment d'échec puisque le rôle de la
police c'est de prévenir ce type
d'attaqués ces attentats après
effectivement si on veut entre
guillemets passer notre temps à réaliser
des enquêtes a posteriori c'est fort
divertissant mais si vous voulez on est
quand même en situation d'échec puisque
l'assaillant après tout ce qu'il avait à
faire
je ne crois pas qu'il ait été
interrompue par les forces de l'ordre il
a tout simplement pris la fuite et il a
été interpellé par la suite et s'il
avait été malheureusement plus dangereux
ou mieux entraînés il aurait peut-être
fait davantage de victimes et donc
écoutez ça ça reste ça reste quand même
relativement préoccupant moi j'espère
que l'on va pas avoir à confronter ou à
affronter une nouvelle vague d'attentats
sur paris et sur l'ensemble du
territoire français
aujourd'hui avait lieu effectivement une
commande ya une étape décisive de du
procès des auteurs de l'attentât de
charlie hebdo puisque une revenante de
syrie devait être auditionnée et
s'exprimer sur les possibilités d'un de
ceux de survie derrière boumédiène donc
il s'agit il s'agit d'une revenante qui
devait être auditionné cet après midi
donc on avait également un procès contre
la presse puisqu'il s'agit c'était le
jour annoncé en plus qu'à de l'audience
comment dire qui confrontait le maire de
goussainville soupçonné d'avoir été
fichier s et le journal l'express lui
même avait donné la date du 25 septembre
pour l'audience
donc si vous voulez la presse et la
liberté de la presse sont attaqués de
toutes parts l'extrémisme gagne du
terrain sur le territoire national et si
vous voulez les slogans et les discours
sur le séparatisme n'y changeront
absolument rien ce qu'attendent les
français aujourd'hui ce sont des actes
significatifs et des actes concrets pour
pouvoir prétendre à une vie en sécurité
et qu'ils semblaient être les actes
concrets pour une vie en sécurité
écoutez ça peut pas se résumer en une
phrase je crois qu'il faut faire table
rase de tout ce qui existe déjà de tous
les petits gadgets et les petits
dispositif qui a été mis en place et
redéfinir une politique de sécurité en
report en reprenant je dirais les les
fondamentaux parce que ce qui se dit des
défaillances de la lutte anti terroriste
pourrait s'appliquer au trafic de
stupéfiants aux violences urbaines et à
tout le reste
moi maintenant je sais que en tout cas
les journalistes ne sont à l'abri nulle
part al qaïda que l'on croyait morte et
enterrée à candiac surgi au coeur de la
capitale au moment où on s'y attendait
le moins
donc je sais qu'un certain nombre de ces
journalistes réalisaient des enquêtes
sur l'islam politique sur les
défaillances justement de la lutte
antiterroriste j'ai été encore moi même
consulté par charlie hebdo cette semaine
sur le sujet donc écouter ça reste
relativement préoccupant et moi je
serais beaucoup plus soulagée j'ai là la
fin de la journée quand on saura que
effectivement l'enquète suit son cours
et que l'ensemble de la capitale aura
été sécurisés convenablement vous le
vous lisiez tout à l'heure le pays subit
depuis quelques temps déjà plusieurs
menaces
on imagine forcément que que c'est un
acte qui ne vous étonne pas forcément
non mais voyez pour qui connaît
l'organigramme de la police nationale et
de la lutte antiterroriste
je constate que depuis de le début de la
journée on parle de la drpj c'est à dire
la direction régionale de la police
judiciaire
on parle de la dgs i mais on n'a jamais
prononcé
l'acronyme de la drpp qui est en charge
de la lutte antiterroriste sur la
capitale par semprun la direction du
renseignement de la préfecture de police
qui avait été conspué par la commission
parlementaire enquête parlementaire qui
avait été menée par le député ciotti
puisqu'elle avait été également mises en
échec par homme qui avait l'art qu'on
met également au moment comment dire de
l'attentât collombat qui avait
grièvement blessé de nos collègues
motards donc ciblé c'est une affaire en
fait une histoire sans fin
a priori la préfecture de police et ses
services intérieurs ont le plus grand
mal à sécuriser la capitale et la petite
couronne qui coûtait soit effectivement
on attend le prochain attentat
savez-vous confrères
je me permet de les citer vos confrères
de mediapart ont diffusé un article
d'hier qui parle des failles de la lutte
antiterroriste et il ya une phrase au
milieu de l'article qui est évoqué comme
une fatalité c'est à dire qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de victimes de terroristes je
cite et il y en aura encore ok coûté si
on se contente effectivement de faire ce
type de déclarations en se disant que
c'est inéluctable c'est la fatalité il
ya des gens qui meurent et des gens qui
sont blessés on n'y peut rien c'est à ce
moment-là faisons des économies
démantelons les services de
renseignement est investi sur l'argent
dans votre chose mais je veux dire pour
qui prétend au professionnalisme et à la
démocratie et aux services publics
on n'a pas le droit d'envisager
justement le terrorisme comme une
fatalité on se doit d utiliser tous les
recours possibles pour pouvoir l'année
entière
merci beaucoup dans un manoir d'avoir
été avec nous à cet après midi sur rt
france je rappelle que vous êtes délégué
syndical vigie police merci beaucoup